Evon asks if you could clone yourself
would you Evan this is a tremendous
question and a great one to end the year
especially because I announced that I'm
going away with my family for two weeks
this is easy of question as they've come
I would 100% mean this is the bet I
really wish this technology existed
because I would take that person Gary -
who is actually Gary - the clone version
anyway I would take the cloned version
and I would make that person spend every
waking moment with my family
and said hold you guys what's that why
is that funny what's that oh you know I
don't care keep this keep this keep this
rolling by the way first of all no no
editing here you know I don't think you
understand the the fact that matter is
is they're the same person
are you saying that Melissa maybe that
was an insight that we didn't maybe I
love my business more than my favorite
sorry it's a tough way to end the show
and the year the bottom line is starting
that d-roc has become the cynical one
but Steve the bat and the torch has been
passed I would take the equal version of
it and have that person sit at home
every minute and be with my family
because then I would be able to
accomplish the two things that I want at
one time and so that would be the answer
oh crap wait subscribe I need
subscriptions because I can't push this
many right hooks in social so subscribe